i'm sure there's a tremendous amount of
ptsd that
one would suffer from that kind of a
loss and that kind of an experience
i mean i'm i'm not sure exactly how long
this
this specific chapter of your life was
but
sort of after that like what did you do
like how did you
cope with this and transition out of
this sort of epoch
of your life it's a good question and
i'm not even
sure but i did do
therapy after september 11th um
i after going through like 10 therapists
i finally found one that i thought
understood
the depth of my despair and pain
and and she was very understanding
and and she very much wanted to help me
with everything in her she wanted to
help me
survive it and one of the things
she taught me that i think became the
most valuable
tool that she taught me was to
compartmentalize your grief
so i went in 2002 i left the mayor's
office in new york and i
on a detail i went to work for the
secretary of health and human services
to help
secretary thompson build a command and
control
system into health and human services
after the anthrax attack
so i was going back and forth to
washington dc and
i would fly and so i would fly from
laguardia to
reagan airport of under just under an
hour flight
and i would always get in a window seat
i'd get on the plane i'd put the shade
down i'd put
my head against the shade and i put on
like these like the bose noise canceling
headphones
and when the as soon as the wheels
lifted off
i would put on andrea bocelli's voice
because he was the voice that spoke to
me his music spoke to me
in my heart and i would put my head
against the
window and i would cry
heavy for an hour
but then when the wheels hit the tarmac
at reagan airport i lifted the shade up
i took off the headphones and i tried my
best
to move forward and deal with life
and that worked for me now
she didn't say this is what your
compartment is this is what time of day
you do it she didn't tell me
it was any of those things but for
people that are in difficult
places if you can compartmentalize
that pain in that hurt
for some time during each day
and for the rest of that day try and do
positive things it will help you
survive the pain in the darkness
and it it helped me get through it
and then in 2009
2008 2009 when i got back involved with
mayor giuliani
and with the families that
gave me strong purpose again so i
survived
by compartmentalizing and just trying to
get
through each day until something else
came into my life
that i've started to feel really
passionate about and that i could
have an impact on
the family's lives and um
and that's that's what really got me
strong again was getting back in with
the families
and and finding out that i had this
voice which i didn't know i had
and that that it would help our
community
and it would help uh us with the mantra
never forget which we promised after 9
11. we promised everyone never forget
and as long as i have a voice that's
how i'm going to speak that's what i'm
going to speak about
um did you ever did you ever experiment
with any sort of
uh like ptsd therapies
like like cannabis or mdma or i know
there's a lot of different things that
people are utilizing especially navy
seals i talked to one guy
who uh who did a lot of stuff with
cannabis and md and
mdma and he said it helped a lot because
i know there's a lot especially people
in the combat veterans
who commit suicide on a daily basis
because of
ptsd you never experimented with
anything
anything like that so no no drug therapy
i know it works for them uh i it was
never for me i've always been a
government guy so i'm not allowed to do
like not i'd like smoke this or that
right
they do random drug tests on you and
stuff um i
i do drink but that's sometimes not the
best thing if you're having a hard time
uh but
back in i guess around those times
around 2009
10 i joined this group called ride to
recovery
the ride to the number two recovery and
it's
basically it's bicycling with 100 or 200
injured warriors and you know and you do
it for a week
you go out you do 60 70 80 miles a day
and
and you build this community back and
all that and that that helped me a lot
just being out there just being with
people you could help people who could
help you
getting to know other people who are as
patriotic as i was
so for me that for me that was helpful
without
doing the drug therapy stuff
and i left room
for new friendships and new
relationships
right i said earlier i lost over 100 of
my friends
i mean that was basically my whole life
you know these are the men i hung out
with every day
when i came back to new york i i went on
a little tour for a while when i came
back to new york
in 2005 uh
i thought what i needed was to have
new quality male friends
that didn't happen
but i wound up without going too long
into it i wound up
becoming friends with this group of
brazilian women believe it or not
interesting random right how did that
happen
i just was going to this italian
restaurant this
another debra different deborah was the
bartender
and she saw like the look on my face
she's very cute she's very friendly
very brazilian people are very um warm
and loving
and and she
i mean she liked me but she kind of felt
bad for me i think and
and one night she said i get off at
9 30. what are you doing i said whatever
you're doing and
and she took me down the block to her
friend's house apartment
and knocked on the door open the door up
there's a
irish guy with a baby
and uh he's like come in come in come in
we go on
he we sit down on the couch he's like
sit down with me
we're bouncing the baby back and forth
and
his wife lorana another brazilian girl
[Music]
puts beers in our hand and he's like
matt is like just wait
and they turn the music up and the next
thing i know there are about 10
gorgeous brazilian girls in this
apartment
dancing and matt's like not bad huh
and i was like this is i like this
that's [ __ ] amazing and
so these brazilian women
you know got to know my story and they
they wanted to help they wanted to be
a part of my life and they took me to
brazil twice
they took me to their homes where they
grew up
i met their families and it really
like taught me that i could be happy
again
uh in my life and that unexpected things
would come into my life
uh and it also taught me that i'm not in
control
that yeah totally he the big h
i was reminded that he was still in
control of my life and
and he also has a sense of humor because
i thought i had to meet these quality
guys he was like
how about some quality brazilian girls
oh yeah i don't think anything could be
better than
quality brazilian girls well they
drinking and dancing and they loved
eating good food they loved me they they
took care of me
they um they were with me
every night go here go there let's do
this let's do that
i was always invited i was always a part
of their team and uh
uh it really brought me back
but that's beautiful man that's because
it is it is beautiful i'm still friends
with all of them they live all over the
world and i'm still friends with all of
them
um but in in order for me to have
that opportunity to give that
opportunity
a chance i had to get through the hard
times for sure every day every minute of
every day
and for me it was music andrea mochelli
for me it was um my family for sure my
family
i don't know what i would have done i'm
not married i mean my my siblings and my
mom and dad
um
but the compartmentalization andrea
bocelli's voice
spoke to me and just trying to get
through
every day the pain of it and trying to
do something good
and be strong i i don't know man i i
i'm glad i did it in the end because i
met these brazilian girls and then i met
a bunch of 911 families who i didn't
they weren't fire department families
they were other 911 families
who i got close with and and look in the
end i i met this
amazing amazing navy seal named jay
redman
who survived being shot eight times
and is this amazing positive
warm american hero
right he is of the quality of
captain terry hatton and captain patty
brown and fireman chris blackwell and
fireman uh michael lynch like um
it took that shh that took over 10 years
it's it's a long time but but i i
i have another man who i admire
respect who's my friend
and i feel very close with and i feel he
would have fit in with my friends
if they were still around you know
it's ten years a long time to wait
yeah a long time to wait
but i'm so happy to be alive
i feel like i have great purpose
foreign